مصعب بكين واشنطن لبث الدفء في علاقات
البلدين انطلقت اليوم بزياره وفد رفيع
المستوى ولمده ثلاثه ايام سيجول الوفد
الامريكي في دول المنطقه الصين وكوريا
الجنوبيه الجنوبيه واليمن ويتراس الوفد
الامريكي دانيال كريتامبرنج مساعد وزير
الخارجيه لشؤون شرق اسيا والمحيط الهادئ
وكبيره مديرين مجلس الامن القومي لشؤون
الصين وتايوان لورا روزنبرج
[موسيقى]
هذا هو تعتزم الاداره الامريكيه ارسال
الوفد تنفيذا للوعد الذي قطعه الشهر
الماضي في بالي الرئيس سان الامريكي
والصيني لمحاوله اعاده العلاقات
لى طريقها الصحيح حينها اعلن الرئيسان ان
الدولتين ستواصلان اداره المنافسه بين
البلدين بشكل مسئوله واستكشاف مجالات
التعاون المحتمله في الاثناء سيعد الوفد
الامريكي لزياره وزير الخارجيه للصين
المقرره اوائل العام المقبل والتي ستكون
الاولى من نوعها لدبلوماسي امريكي بارز
منذ اربع سنوات وتحدث بيضا وشي خصوصا عن
مواضيع خلافيه منها مستقبل سيوان والقيود
الامريكيه على واردات المنتجات التقنيه
الصينيه
التوترات بين امريكا والصين تصعدت
مشاهدينا ببطء منذ عقود لكنها ارتفعت بشكل
كبير بعد ان شلنا الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب حربا تجاريا حمائيه معصيه
ومنذ توليه منصبه العام الماضي لم يفعل
بيضن الكثير لعكس سياسات ترامب التجاريه
وخلال اجتماعهما الشهر الماضي ابدا
الرئيسان الصيني والامريكي رغبتهما في
تفادي تحول المنافسه بينهما الى نزاع
التوافق الظاهر بين شي وبيضن لا يمنع وجود
خلافات اكبر لعل من ابرزها ملف تايوان
فعلها مش قمه مجموعه ال 20 حضر الرئيس
الصيني واشنطن من انبيكين تعتبر تايوان
خطا احمر يجب عدم تخطيطي وسائل الاعلام
صينيه نقلت عن شيجيم بين قوله ان مساله
تايوان في صميم المصالح الجوهريه للصين
والقاعده للاساس السياسي للعلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه حينها قال الرئيس الامريكي ان
افعال الصين العدوانيه بشان تايوان تعرض
السلام للخطر في المنطقه
محور وجدا الاخر في العلاقه بين الدولتين
هو محاوله الولايات المتحده اعاقه الصين
في المجال التقنيه الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وقع في اغسطس الماضي الرقائق
الالكترونيه المسمى اختصارا بيتشبس ووعد
بمليارات الدولارات في شكل حوافز واعانات
لتعزيز انتاج اشباه الموصلات على الاراضي
الامريكيه
بموجب القانون تمنع الشركات الاجنبيه من
بيع اشباه الموصلات المتطوره ومعدات تصنيع
الرقائق للشركات الصينيه كما قد يواجه
المواطنون الامريكيون والمقيمون فيها
عقوبات اذا تعاملوا مع الشركات الصينيه
وفقا للقواعد الجديده لكن هل ستتحدث
القيود هذه تاثيرا على الصناعات الصينيه
بحسب مختصين التاثير سيكون وقتي ينفق فقط
ففي مقابله صحيفه فاينال تايمز قال الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه ان اي سي اليابانيه
التقنيه باك يوكي موريتا ان تاثير
العقوبات مؤقت بينما سيستمر وجود الصين
بقوه في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي واعتبر
المسؤول الياباني انه من غير الممكن تجاه
القدره التنافسيه للصين في التكنولوجيا
وانها ستصبح واحده من القوى التي يحسب لها
حساب على المدى الطويل مريضه اضاف ان بعض
المجالات قد تشهد انخفاضا في سرعه
التطورها الا ان ذلك لن يقف البحث
والتطوير في الصين ولن يكون بالامكان
اعاقتها تقنيه كما حدث سابقا مع الاتحاد
السوفيتي
[موسيقى]